1378 kilometer australien mit singapore
airlines täglich im airbus a380 ab
zürich paris und george für mich als
ersten garage mit dem die ganze welt
gereist
der alt bmw hat mittlerweile fast eine
halbe million kilometer rufen zahlen
[Musik]
das ist
in spanien kann erklärt
denn damals kommt gar same kräuterdorf
greift und sind losgefahren
der glücklos orthofer wahlen
hemmschwelle finden und dann gemeinsam
ihres lager verbringen
schlussendlich sind ziemlich gelandet
[Gelächter]
hinter dem gang vor dem unscheinbaren
familie öffnen sich in skurrile kroos
muss überall stand kunstwerk von george
die looks like großartig sie die eine
alphütte aus wir nutzen den holzhof noch
immer durch eine fleischwurst und
bassersdorf schädling ich bin was pastor
das ist unsere hinterhof mit viel liebe
und arbeit und energie
zurzeit müssen hartz iv in nur vier
jahren sind da noch nicht gemacht
wir bleiben vielleicht noch zwei drei
oder vier jahre sehr gut was die jetzt
erzählen
ich hatte ein gutes leben kann mich
nicht beklagen
ich vermisse überhaupt habe die beste
frau auf der welt
wir hatten ein großartiges leben machten
eine motorradreise um die welt
hier begann ich als mode-ikone
arbeitsbewilligung ich arbeite am
berühmten opernhaus einstieg ins
filmgeschäft
später unterrichtete ich alte kunst
treten wir tagsüber arbeitete careys als
krankenschwester schlussendlich
wechselte ich an die fotoabteilung der
universität also careys das ist deine
küche
es ist eigentlich george küche er kocht
und wie kommt er zu dieser einrichtung
dort hat sie gebaut sind
er hat diese schöne kombination
geschreinert als wir einzogen
entschieden wir dass wir einen satz
anständiges porzellan kaufen
und dieser sommer war stammt aus georgia
ehemaligem antiquitätengeschäft in basel
aus der eschen vorstadt in basel
das sind nicht die einzige höchste
kriegst du den honig ja er ist hast du
keine angst gestochen zu werden
nein ich bin oft hier oben und mache den
garten
was bedeutet
ich bin ein land ich wollte immer
entweder im absoluten luxus in der stadt
oder dann auf dem land leben wir
entschieden dass das stadtleben mich gut
ist für uns also brachten wir ein wenig
land leben in die stadt hat sich gelohnt
wir haben guten honig und viel freude
chris und ich haben gemeinsam etwas er
recht in diesen momenten
sony gingen in honig wein probieren
gerne ich hab schon richtig durst die
zwei älteren tieren thonicke
[Musik]
ich habe viel über das lucky country
gelesen australien das glückliche land
in erster linie heißt es bist du machst
dann doch selbst wenn die australier
gesang der nordsee ein altes sprichwort
lautet gib einem australier ein stück
draht und eine zange an unser krank
alles flick das war schon so als wir
hierher kam der australier wussten sich
zu helfen wenn es durchs dach reinregnet
nun da musst du halt in wassereimer
darunter stellen würde es ist ein
glückliches land ein grund warum ich
damals die schweiz verließ und leider
beobachte ich das hier auch immer näher
alles was in der schweiz nicht verboten
war war obligatorisch
sie sei das hastig als eine art ist wie
kann es sein dass künstler hältst du
sowas nicht aus ich wollte meine
freiheit
ich will mir nicht immer überlegen ist
es nur obligatorisch oder verboten o2
hat eine lange und glückliche beziehung
was ist euer geheimnis wir lieben uns
ganz einfach wir teilen unsere leben
sind keine einzelgänger
wir nehmen am leben des anderen teils
man muss miteinander reden wenn ich
etwas beschäftigt teile es
george nein zum abschied ich mir sie mir
unbedingt berühmt
immerhin er als mitgebaut
[Musik]
dollar
das wort zu versehen
natürlich zeigt wo das berührende
stellen
in unserem sinne
[Musik]
die caris & george klick findet man nur
bischof selber sie sind um die ganze
welt gereist und irgendwann merkt das
klima da ist williams
[Musik]
die die sternsinger strahle sind so groß
dass ich damals verkehrsmittel müsse
wechsle ich pflege 2000 kilometer von
sydney nach cairns in norderstedt zipfel
vom kontinent
und heiß
[Musik]
hier lernt gerade mal auf 0,01 prozent
vor ausstrahlung flache und betrieb für
alle australischen die optiken 70 orten
und 700 pflanzen international
[Musik]
eine moschee vor schick vor der
einzigartigen natur vielfalt
verschrieben hat ist alex chapman
die biologin sabine wie lang das ist das
paradies nogi schön dich kennenzulernen
was machst du hier ich untersuche wie
sich der durchmesser und bäumen
verändert ich messe die durchflussmenge
von wasser und wunsch wie kommt das
wasser den baum hoch und der kohlenstoff
aus der luft in die wurzeln rund darum
es gerade hier laufen alle daten
zusammen und werden gespeichert toller
arbeitsplatz ein wunderbarer ort
mein büro aber es ist auch gefährlicher
als im büro oder nicht wörtlich es gibt
schlimmeres und all die insekten und
schlangen eigentlich sind es die pflanze
die gefährlich sind die hier ist
gefährlich sie hat den übernamen warten
wenn die dich erwischt dauert es lange
bis du wieder freikommt die dornen gehen
alle in die gleiche richtung
du bleibst hängen
[Musik]
bevor wir wieder filme platz
instruktionen haben wir einen prenzel
baum vor dem musst du dich in acht
nehmen
er hat diese feinen härchen wenn die in
deiner haut beraten bekommst du dich
nicht wieder raus endlich gefährlich
richtig gefährlich schmerzt höllisch
darin markieren wir alle mit
warnschildern die bäume können sie nicht
groß werden die meisten sind klein wie
dieser hier ja ich kann die härchen
sehen wenn du die berührst wirst du
einen stechenden bränden schmerz darin
bestehen wir darauf dass alle lange
hosen und meistens auch lange tragen
messen wie sich der durchmesser der
bäume
im tagesverlauf zieht sich der baum
zusammen und dehnt sich weiter aus
die daten kommen von den sensoren durch
diese krank und werden hier gesammelt
hier siehst du wie sich der durchmesser
verändert während danach dehnt sich der
stamm aus weil er wasser aufsaugt und im
morgengrauen zieht er sich zusammen
die daten zeigen uns wie sich die
wassermengen wären trocken und
regenperioden war und wir sehen wie der
kohlenstoff aus der luft verarbeitet
provisionen wechselwirkung zwischen
pflanzen und dem klima
wir erforschen unbekannte problem die
welt stellt uns vor große unsicherheit
wir wissen dass sich das klima verändert
wir wissen aber nicht wie die welt
darauf reagieren
ich will das wissen ich will wissen ob
dieser war halt und 50 oder 100 jahren
noch hier sein wird
momentan können wir das nicht sagen hier
in australien haben wir nur einen dünnen
landstrich mit dem richtigen klima
verlegenheit
wird dieser wald überleben wenn es zu
warm oder zu trocken ist
bei meiner arbeit
diese probleme betreffen regenwälder auf
der ganzen welt
die regenwälder kämpfen mit großen
veränderungen sei es das klima oder die
abruzzen meine erkenntnisse aus diesem
wald werden auf der ganzen welt
anwendbar
zu alex ganz schön außer gewöhnlich
einen kran mitten im regenwald ist der
einzige baumkronen kran in der südlichen
hemisphäre
es gibt noch welche in panama und
südostasien
aber der südlichen hemisphäre ist dies
der einzige krank den mann in die
baumkronen gelangt ziemlich
außergewöhnlich also
[Musik]
alex erklärt mir in finnland ganz andere
pflanze und tier war am boden
wir haben ob eine andere welt
[Musik]
hier in einer baumkrone was ihr genau
das was ihnen verschiedene vorschläge am
meisten interessiert fotos in dieser
[Musik]
das ist ein tragbares messgerät für die
photosynthese hier vorne ist der send
wurden wir können also ein platz
einklemmen und messen wie viel co2 das
blatt aufnimmt und wie viel wasser ist
dabei hat wir messen also den
wirkungsgrad der photosynthese eines
platz diesen wert können wir dann auf
den ganzen regenwald hochrechnen
[Musik]
der gewaltexzess 40 millionen von drei
lecks gefunden
der wald bei klimatische unterschied
zwischen frage und rochen sie der post
der markante anstieg von der temperatur
in der letzten jahre kann der große zahl
von bäumen zum verschwinden bringen lag
siegen ii dramatisch aber sicher an
[Musik]
der alex zeigt mir dass nacht mit grünen
ameisen
ich hatte jetzt gemeint er macht uns
spaß war mir seit die chance
sie schmeckt nach zitrone
dringend muss es ausprobieren sie haben
einen natürlichen geschmack macht sich
versuch sie am kopf und unterleib
abreißen
- die kieler dazu ein starker geschmack
ja sehr stark
das ist irgendwie ein konzentrat wenn
die angreifen oder sich verteidiger
brauchen sie diese säure
ganz schön stark auf zitronentee hast du
einfach ameisen mit heißem wasser auf
seit wann interessierst du dich so für
pflanzen
mich hat die natur schon immer
interessiert ich wuchs in england auf
mit dem dokumentarfilm von david s das
hat mich immer schon fasziniert
als ich meinem bruder neulich so dass
von hier oben schickte erinnerte er mich
an meinen geburtstag
ich glaube es war der 13 er schenkte mir
damals diesen sean connery ich war im
urwald liebt madison als der ich träumte
also schon in diesem alter davon ein
wilde und exotische orte abzuhauen
[Musik]
unglaublich aber wahr
frage
die
die begegnung mit dem alex mir klar
zeigt wird zerbrechlich was das paradies
ist und wie wenig wir über die
auswirkungen von klimawandel wissen
[Musik]
mitfahrer überqueren
im tropischen norden von australien
[Musik]
die gegend ist berühmt-berüchtigt für
salzwasser krokodil immer wieder kunst
so tödlicher unfall nicht wenige welte
am liebsten die gefährliche jahres rote
vehement mensch und krokodil sammeln
aber das weiß ist charlie manolis
krokodil forscher und wissenschaftler im
croke park in darwin als erste bilanz
ihres krokodil zeigen war in lecce acht
im krokodilzoo gestorben es war das
größte krokodil das jedem hafen runter
gefahren wurde
es ist also ein ganz spezielles team für
die transport- und mitarbeiter von
charlies tod die offenbacher fixiert das
war schon länger klar
letzte nacht ist es gestorben stell dir
vor du begegnest zu einem tier bei einem
romantischen mondschein bat ich habe
noch nie von so nah gesehen wenn sich
ein tier von dieser größe erwischt aus
dem null chancen zu berlin 0
aber sie sind ein teil unseres lebens
ein wichtiger teil stimmt die menschen
hier norden müssen mit diesen tieren
leben
es geht also darum der population so zu
kontrollieren dass die menschen die
tiere akzeptieren du kannst das von den
wölfen in der schweiz
die bauern wollen sie nicht weil sie
ihre schafe rest die krokodile fressen
wie menschen sie fressen alles
unsere herausforderung besteht darin die
öffentlichkeit dazu zu bringen dass sie
diese tiere wollen wir mussten die tiere
also irgendwie wertvoll machen das kann
tourismus sein oder die zucht
wir haben jetzt ein nachhaltiges
programm wir haben zahlen die touristen
in unserem park wir haben eine
fleischindustrie exportieren krücke die
leute und das schafft arbeitsplätze
krokodile sind also wäre es wenn das ist
unser inkubator da haben wir
normalerweise bis zu 12.000 euro drin
leider bist du zum ende der prozesse
hier aber du kannst mir helfen
wir gehen raus
60 km
sie kommen mit 68 kleinen szenen aus dem
ei das ist unglaublich
sie finden immer den empfindlichsten
teil des fingers vorne oben siehst du
den kleinen weißen da das ist der kann
das öffnen du siehst alle zähne sind
schon da
ich habe kein kugelschreiber dabei die
beißen sich problemlos blut
du kannst du es sei unglaublich
die haut ist so weit
kaum zu glauben dass so etwas niedliches
mal sechs meter lang
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die zuchtstation von rocco nieborg ich
veröffentliche gesperrt georgi und
justine müssen des großes man legt die
ifa
es wird immer noch sturm aber bist du
sicher dass da nur 1 training passt auf
wenn es hoch kommt vor wenigen minuten
lief erzählt es gibt keine chance wenn
dieses krokodil attackiert
hoffen wir machen das nicht zum ersten
mal
der vertriebssitz comeback weiter
stürmen sicherheit
das krokodil probiert chiffriert in dem
es sich um die eigene achse
merkel zog er macht nur auf linie wegen
der c liga vor
hermann theresa braun
die so ganz wohl ich im rennen
52 hätte von mir
es ist ziemlich aufregen
sie sind fünf zentimeter von mir sind
und ich habe eigentlich das sagen wohin
schneider zu erhalten und ich hoffe
andere haben mit einer note
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir binden ihm jetzt das mal zu das
krokodil hat unglaubliche kraft beim zug
ist aber fast keine kraft um das moor zu
öffnen und der dünne schnur recht
es ist ganz ruhig jetzt aber sie haben
diese ausbrüche sehr schnell erschöpft
müssen sich erholen
plötzlich wollen sie sich wieder auf
wenn er sich benimmt können wir
glücklich sein aber wir müssen immer
aufpassen
der hals des krokodils ist zu stark wir
können es problemlos ziehen
doch dass mein auf jungs
er studierte sie an der box er nach
allem was ich aber ab da ich mir klar
dass man sohnes tieren mit seiner kraft
nur so transportieren
und so bringen lied von charlie das
krokodil
[Musik]
[Applaus]
höfer australier vertiefend krokodil
dank dem charly manolis entschieden team
sind die tiere in der innen attraktion
über arbeitsplatz schaffen
da wird natur und mensch
aufeinandertreffen trennen konflikte
entstanden
ich weiß wie man muss akzeptieren dass
es die absolut sicherheit nicht geht und
probiere mit der natur zum eklat
[Musik]
für mich und acht kilometer bis zur
nächsten zwei gegner ja unglaublich das
zeigt wieder einmal wie groß das land
ist nichts so bleibt während der schweiz
500 kilometer am stück fahren
[Musik]
es geht wieder durch die krimi die
region samar israels schweiz und hat
aber nur 8 30 uhr
umso überraschter bin aber wenn ich das
hier gesehen in grenzen mit in
australien
auf dem schild lasse quarantäne station
früchte gemüse oder honig dabei nichts
dann kennst du also die
quarantänebestimmungen häufig aus
standen also warum eine quarantäne
station mitten in australien damit keine
solchen und schädlinge nach
westaustralien angesteckt werden
du kannst du den future angriffen
aus schokolade das wichtigste das ist
alles captain ausrüstung
[Musik]
reste von zu eigen
gibb river road
auf meine frage ich mich schon auf
einige aber solang sie mit die durch die
gegend
[Musik]
die legendär überlandstrecken ist nur in
der druck hat sich bevor man denn wenn
es weniger absolviert
[Musik]
da stecken blieben stiegen wieder ein
charakterbild und nicht reden
[Musik]
dieser wird ein steiniger weg und ich
muss jetzt was nachfolger finden
und seele dennis fliess beziehungen
kommen
das ist der vorteil vom endlosen und
mancher outback ich gehe einfach vorstoß
ab und fahren und die natur verzuge
nacht wieder weg von der zivilisation
war das in der schweiz nur möglich
[Musik]
das sind moment war mir immer wahnsinnig
liebe
jede und jeden andrea klaric warum der
kontinent glücklich macht mini
erkenntnis dass klick nicht zwingend
einen ort gebunden sie so bin ich dann
einig werden schienen persönlichen
horizont offen bleibt überall auf der
welt finden
ich reise wieder vergibt obwohl ich in
der hochsaison der axpo grafik manche
sehen in der unberührten natur mit mir
ziemlich liefern
[Musik]
das macht die unendliche landschaft mit
dem anschein
[Musik]
mochte versorgen das ist eine der
häufigsten sprich ist die unicredit die
vermeintliche freiheit sorge nimmt die
tracht in lahr ii
[Musik]
es macht maxis ich kannte ewig also
wieder vorn
[Musik]
den themen noch er gehört viel ich doch
nicht wegschaut macht das komisch
in dem action volk entdeckt
die thailändische motto von denen wir
wissen dass sie überhaupt gibt
[Musik]
mit der zeremonie zentral von der city
ich lehre und ich will der honig finden
und wenn ich die grafische vor
und in der minenstadt newman fallen
wieder einmal wichtige spiele in china
schaffen
[Musik]
emotionen mancher und ihre geschichte
auf min raise 12 380 kilometern der
australier
[Musik]
12 1378 km australien mit globetrotter
dem spezialist für maßgeschneiderte
reisen weltweit globetrotter punkte